how are you guys doing today
pretty good how are you doing excellent
i just want to start with
congratulations on the movie
uh and jumping right on in uh tiffany i
think i'm going to start with you
and um ask you uh how exactly were you
cast because i thought you had to be in
godzilla versus kong
to be in this movie
i know with these two right
know um just joking around you were
great
i wish i wish i was um
yeah i guess i'm kind of the only one
who didn't know really anyone in the
situation at all
um i just normal boring audition
you know oh you get the audition you go
to the casting office
you read it with the casting director um
and then i did it i thought there's
probably no way i'm getting this
uh and then a day later they said george
saw your tape and he loves it and two
days after that they were like
waiting for netflix approval and it was
really
it was a very quick easy process
honestly
that's amazing uh that i can't even
imagine that phone call
um i am curious for the three of you um
i'm curious
listen i really like george's work a lot
both in front of and behind the camera
um what is he like on set as a director
is he more like the fincher method where
he's doing a lot of takes
or is he more like the clint eastwood
method where it's like one or two takes
and you're moving on
well i would quickly after watching that
little girl's responses being so
clever the latter
it's the latter but i mean it's not like
uh it's not like the guy would
let something go by if it wasn't there
or if you wanted another one he wouldn't
stop you from having it but
he knows what he wants like he said he's
he's cutting as he's going
along so uh he knows what he wants and
uh and he moves on
which makes for a shorter day and which
makes more time the next day and
once again it eases everything up on the
set
for everyone i i think he has to do with
the fact that he's also an actor
you know an actor director of course and
that like clintus would
and we hate wasting time we hate a
million takes
so he knows that that's why we move very
fast
as well right is uh the direction coming
from an actor it's it's half the way
there before
you know if before uh before it uh
direction is presented it's already it's
interesting
uh one of the things that i like about
movies is when they don't try to explain
everything
you know the imagination is the most
powerful tool to enjoy something
um saying that this movie does not
explain
um how uh the end of the world sort of
happens
and i'm curious if you guys came up with
your own theories or does it not matter
i didn't come up with a theory because
the character doesn't know um what's
going on so for me
i don't i don't really try to know more
than the character if that makes sense
so i i don't have a theory i didn't come
up with one
no me neither yeah we we were all
taken aback you know we were taken by
surprise by this
thing of course i think about many
different things me as the mian
uh and you know the planet has been
through so many different changes
in the last millions of years and and we
just accelerated
this you know new catastrophe i focused
on the fact that i thought there was a
that there was some something that
happened and actually you know when i
was a kid they had all those
mini-series on you know the world
blowing itself up when the arms race was
going on
i think i caught some of those images of
those tv shows when i was a kid that
complete utter devastation in these
cities
and that's where i saw my wife and my
kids having to work their way through to
find some bunker somewhere where we're
gonna meet
just the hell and even though that was
going on still we still we headed down
there didn't we damien
oh yes when the makeup was still open